[موسيقى]
الفنان البريطاني
ساشا جوفري معروف في جميع أنحاء العالم
بلوحاته التجريدية واسعة النطاق
التي تصور السياسة العالمية
والقضايا الإنسانية والطبيعة ،
وأهم شيء يمكنك القيام به كفنان
هو عدم التركيز على المنتجات
التي تصنعها
ولكن أن تعيش حياتك  في نعمة ،
وما سيحدث بعد ذلك
هو أنك ستستعير لحظة ستأتي
وستستعيرها
وستخلق شيئًا سحريًا
في دبي خلال الوباء
الذي شرع فيه في مشروعه الفني الأكثر طموحًا ،
وهو
مستوحى من الإغلاق والموقع
أحب أن أبتكر في دبي ، لدي
مساحة السلام والهدوء
لأتركه بمفرده بالفعل لإنشاء
هذه القطعة ، تمثل رحلة الإنسانية
انفصال الاتصال والعزلة أثناء
الوباء ، قدم
الأطفال من أكثر من 140 دولة
رسومات تخطيطية ليتم ختمها على
القماش الذي
شعرت به  أنه يمكنني إنشاء
لوحة والذهاب في رحلة نأمل أن
تثير
تغييرًا مجتمعيًا مستدامًا حقيقيًا على
مساحة تزيد عن 1800 متر مربع تقريبًا
حجم أربعة ملاعب كرة سلة
تم قطعها
وتأطيرها ، سيتم بيع هذه القطع الستين بالمزاد العلني العائدات التي تذهب إلى جمعيات الأطفال الخيرية.
من الأرض وهذه
مشكلة أكبر بكثير من السرية 19
ستكون تتعلق
بفهم أننا جميعًا
لا يوجد شيء أكثر إرضاءً بالنسبة لي
من الرسم
مثل رحلة الحب والاستكشاف
مرة أخرى على قماشه ، مما يجعل جوفري
يجد مكانه للتواصل  مع
العالم
بطريقته بضربة واحدة في كل مرة